welcome back to the David Pakman show
David is traveling to politican be sure
to check out all of his panels and
debates that he's engaged in this
weekend at politican and be sure to go
over to the Benjamin diction show
YouTube channel and click the subscribe
button alright let's continue with the
news I've moved from Boston to Georgia
from Massachusetts to Georgia and little
did I know that actually I didn't know I
was trying to set it up but I did know
that Georgia is engaging in some of the
most ridiculous voter suppression that
we've seen and they would not be able to
do that had it not been for the Supreme
Court weakening the Voting Rights Act in
Shelby County versus holder basically
saying now giving Georgia particularly
particular counties in Georgia the
ability to do whatever they want to
without having to check with the federal
government with the Department of
Justice before they do it with regard to
voting and now that they no longer have
the responsibility to check in with the
federal government because historically
Georgia and along with other states have
historically used voter suppression
tactics to disenfranchise African
Americans and other minority groups now
that they no longer have to check with
the Department of Justice all they're
just they're just having a field day
creating environments where it takes on
a vote early voting day it takes almost
three hours to vote I want to roll some
footage and this is from Ben brash of
the Atlanta journal-constitution on
Twitter and you can see as he describes
the situation it took these individuals
who were in line for early voting early
voting almost three hours to vote that's
right three hours to vote early this is
just one tactic that the Secretary of
State who happens to be the candidate
for governor of the state has engaged in
to suppress the vote they have been
systematically closing down precincts
across the country across the county
across the state I'll get it right in a
second and those counties those
precincts that they have been closing
have been closing in
predominantly black counties there have
been there was an attempt to
disenfranchise about 400,000 people in a
purge but they dwindled it down and now
about 53,000 people have been
disenfranchised and have been purged
from voting before this election just in
time I mean literally right at the
cutoff to register to vote so right at
the cutoff to register to vote a lot of
people found out that they could not
vote and that they would have to
register again and we don't know yet how
many of them actually had the
opportunity to register in time because
they didn't find out that they were
purged into a few days before the
closing of voter registration here in
Georgia just a handful of tactics I want
to read for you a quote from the ACLU
who have focused on a particular tactic
that is even more nefarious the tactic
that allows individual poll workers to
make the decision whether or not your
signature matches your ID here's the
ACLU early voting in Georgia for the
2018 general election just kicked off on
Monday but already the state has
rejected close to 600 absentee ballots
or applications for an absentee ballot
the culprit state law that require state
laws rather that require election
officials to reject all absentee ballots
and absentee ballot applications if they
believe the signatures within the voters
paperwork do not match each other the
elections officials making these
determinations do not have any formal
education or training to analyze
people's handwriting's and are not
giving any unifying instructions on what
should constitute a mismatch it's left
entirely up to them a layperson Georgia
does not notify voters whether their
ballots are rejected nor does it provide
them an opportunity to consent to the
consent contest rather the determination
so you literally have people who are
accepting absentee ballots who are
saying up that signature doesn't match
the theme of today's show is it's a
feature not a bug this is on purpose
they wanted this loose legend
Latian that gave people at the polls
poll workers the ability to make that
call and we've seen that they they true
this is what they do okay they hold up
these institutions as something that's
hallowed and honored rather and and
cherished and something that is so noble
that it could never really be touched by
the the sickness of partisanship right
and so they're they present this voting
process as a nonpartisan process when in
reality when you have individuals who
can look at your signature and say I
don't think that signature matches
without you having the ability to
contest it or without you even being
notified it clearly enters it presents
the opportunity for them to see a person
who is voting for a candidate that they
do not like and say yeah I don't think
that signature matches but they cover it
up by saying how could you ever impugn
the motives of these poll workers how
could you ever impugn the motives of
these noble people who sacrifice their
time so easily did you see what happened
in 2000 very easily there's this we're
in a hyper partisan society and it is
made so by design right it's a feature
not a bug and so here we are with voter
suppression like we've never seen well
actually that's an incorrect statement
this is this is a standard Republican
tactic to suppress votes I want to play
a small clip of another video that shows
you from the Secretary of State who's
running for governor who not not to you
know had no shame about a subtle dog
whistle to subtle dog whistles in this
video the first is the person who is
getting rejected from being able to vote
is a black girl representing you know
older people there's these are young
kids who are a role playing
but the person who got rejected from
voting is a young black girl and notice
what they say in bright red at the end
of the video they say
it's English only and tell me if these
two tactics are not expressly won a dog
whistle but then to a direct attempt to
suppress the votes of people who English
for who for which English is not their
first language
take a look I've had a designated
advance voting location the process is
exactly the same as voting in person on
Election Day you will complete and sign
a voter certificate provide an
acceptable form of photo identification
and then vote on an electronic voting
machine if you don't have an acceptable
form of photo identification when you're
at the polling location both on Election
Day and during advanced voting you can
vote a provisional ballot if you vote a
provisional ballot you have three days
after election day to return to your
County elections office to show your
photo identification for your ballot to
be accepted and counted if you don't
return your ballot will be rejected and
it will not count
please note that all election related
forms and materials including ballots
are available in English only for more
information please visit our website at
SOS GA gov slash Elections or call us at
404 656 to 871 if you have any questions
this is a public service of Georgia
Secretary of State Brian P Kemp today's
show was made possible in part by simple
habit calm slash Pakman at this point
the benefits of meditation have been
pretty clearly shown to be significant
and that's why I'm so excited that
simple habit is sponsoring the show
which is a guided meditation app that
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app I use the app myself
all you need is 5 to 10 minutes a day
simple habit lets your brain go on a
quick vacation that it very likely
really needs maybe you've been thinking
about giving meditation a try you don't
know where to start simple habit is
really the perfect way to just jump
right into it great for beginners
equally useful for people with
meditation experience they've got quick
meditations for first thing in the
morning
for falling asleep at night for clearing
your mind when you're stressed
meditations for decision-making for
getting motivated getting focused
getting creative hundreds and hundreds
to choose from they're designed and
recorded by well-known names in the
world of meditation and mindfulness and
you can track all of your progress so
whatever time of day it is whatever mood
you're in there's probably a meditation
on simple habit that's perfectly suited
for whatever you're trying to accomplish
with meditation go check it out you can
try it free for seven days at simple
habit calm / Pakman I've put a link
underneath this video